hello everybody happy Friday or just
it's Friday we've made it it's the end
of the week and we're going to check out
some Mortal Kombat because after math
came out this week
yep historically played a fair amount of
Mortal Kombat before we're not like the
best but that's why we like to have fun
it's also an interesting setup because I
think that's the first fighting game
we've done with our different set up yes
the way thing it is throw open the lobby
so you could fight both of us through
you can yeah we're going to join a joint
a room that Ben has made called is it
gob stop is that the one is that our
should gob stopped I should have done
funny word nonsense I GameSpot here on
GameSpot you'll be unfortunately it's
just that yeah so we're mean better I'm
just gonna play against each other
anyone wants to play hop on in we're
just gonna be playing for an hour and
having a good Friday
somebody said pick spawn do you want to
pick spawned you want me to pick spawn
I'm Jonah I'm trying to do it will
settle steep Oh
also mine my lighting is not I don't
have my leg lighting properly setup I
had a new things it's all good
Jake sure that's a miracle right
connections are happening things are
come together but we should you buy the
new Mortal Kombat character separately
that's women yeah it's kind of weird
that they put these characters behind
like a $40 waffle website I hit a button
I'm sorry does that mean challenge to
climb no I didn't I didn't know I got
yeah you hit me hit you hit me with that
that challenge yeah
alone ps4 kind joint through cross play
so I think it's only Xbox and ps4 that
are cross play here attention that's
that's really unfortunate if that's the
case
this is the first time we've been on PC
and we're kind of hoping we'd be able to
do it on ps4 like we usually do but that
didn't work out sadly so I'm gonna go
spawn I guess I don't know how to play
them very well but he's voiced by David
so that's all you really need my little
teaser then you get if you can look in
well if you could look on the stream you
could see my my variant for Robocop is
still potato fide oh really shoot yeah
like like in the little corner that
little box you know that were you
talking about I love it I love to see it
so teaser mean Ben today another potato
mode on after maps DLC and that should
be going up this weekend so look forward
to that
I should be exciting yeah and if you
haven't watched the original one you
should check it out
I got scared by the Joker oh god I am
really dark geez I'm so sorry everybody
it's just cuz it's earlier it's ten
o'clock this is the earliest we were
done I know I like move my setup around
I didn't set up the light and I was like
I don't need it right now and then
turns out I did Fujin so cool though
yeah it's my first time playing him but
I would like to mess around with him cuz
he's in grad I can also turn the
subtitles after four people if they uh
they want to hear what they're saying I
hit up the 3rd Street Saints okay so
he's got lots of guns that's good to
know
oh nice man you're gonna you're gonna
completely work me haven't played this
game in so long
I've had to do a lot of like capture
stuff I wasn't thinking about yeah oh my
god please okay I hit you a little nice
I didn't get a view to get a perfect on
me good lord it's the first one of the
day we're warming up
all right it is worth know I in
switching to the PC
I appreciate the like the proper frame
rates on everything somebody said you're
using keyboard Jesus no not using
keyboard I'm using controller keyboard
if you want to be oh no damn you all my
favorite game is Gibbs war that came out
way too fast and I wasn't ready for the
punchline properly okay I don't know
like any of these noobs so I don't know
like how I'm supposed to play him you
brought wind to a gunfight that would
that's probably a brutality or something
that's got it all right
oh I don't even get my fiddle blow off
Wow well uh I been let's just keep going
let's just keep going man I'm into it
maybe sports actually pretty cool I
haven't got a chance to play it much
actually but spot seems cool yeah he's
got these weird like capes swoopy domes
that I'm used to but I played I played
him a fair amount in Soul Calibur you
know if there's level 11 how the heck
did that happen
levels come at you fast okay for anyone
asking why like I'm so low level in this
game it's because I really put on the
ps4 yeah it's like so my god my 80 hours
played on the ps4
you know don't got any of that here
which sucks I'm exactly that crossed
that cross-platform cross save cross
play future man wherever games like that
so you said Robocop I'll play Robocop
even though I also don't know how to
play Robocop that we've already hit on
all of the new characters boom done yeah
it's that's the stage that's the one
how's the PC version working so far it's
I mean we were able to connect so if
there's a little bit of maybe like
hang-up happening sometimes like it took
a long time for that stuff to load in
yeah it's not unplayable east right so
anyway you can check my microphone cuz I
wanna make sure I'm not like clicking my
controller into it
hmm mostly smooth a little weird
hitching right here but yeah that's fair
know why we're fighting oh I do houses
it's one of these things that's right we
gotta throw okay
I got an angry walk into a into a
good-good stomp God that still oh I
remember that move oh yeah everyone has
like a weird flashback whenever Shiva
doesn't say yeah you're like Oh God
PTSD said oh that's a deception of
posterior that's cool the stage is
really neat oh no I was like oh wait a
minute hold on there's a thing that's
gonna happen it's the name of the room
the name of the room is gain spa you can
actually see it down below and kick my
ass cuz I'm terrible come on Ben don't
go in that was a late win okay I was
tripping oh man it's the UH
wow they have all the stages holy [ __ ]
yeah right dude that's awesome oh no god
I don't know like any of this combos
I've got a little bit I don't know it's
it's a little floaty from the lag I know
by you it's it's not perfect it's not
ideal it's definitely not the best you
can you can feel it for sure just go for
it
wake up fatal blow let's go oh damn I'm
uh I'll bring this back I'm gonna make
it work
why'd you back up don't back up
it's a brutal uh grab there oh no come
on come on oh jeez oh yes you when in
doubt
disappear fall from the ceiling I don't
see the room on the list um hmm that's
weird I was able to see it are what what
platform you plan on we're playing on PC
there's the big thing is it's it's PC oh
did you see that change machine yeah
that looked that is the exact change
machine that used to be at my arcade
that's a kid holy crap that is like
that's a good wrench like how much of
the stuff is like proper license yeah
like that looked almost exactly I'm sure
like they change the name around but
like that the Machine shape and color oh
no I don't remember
no I have I have a list pulled up just
in case I like absolutely no but it
didn't even help me I walked over cop a
few days ago such a good movie do that's
a great movie
it's a it's a wild time for sure
I hope washed in a long time
I watched the the breed like fan made
one where they had like a like two
hundred people make individual scenes
recently mmm that was pretty good
um maybe he'll give a Fujin ago this
time okay I'm gonna go I guess I'll give
I'll give a she burger uh I'm glad that
she's back she's she's a real cool yeah
real cool character oh let's go yeah
unfortunately we're playing on PC and
and it doesn't even have any sort of
cross play with the consoles which is a
bummer also guys this is a little bit of
an earlier start than we usually do
and I think we're only gonna about go
for an hour because it's real busy today
we play for all happening next week
yeah so there's a lot of stuff we're
doing in preparation for play for all
which is our big charity event that
we're doing that's gonna be lasting a
month it's sort of the best dudes III
where we're gonna be like covering
obviously all the conferences you know
Sony just announced that they're gonna
cover the PS 5 on Thursday next week so
you know we're gonna be covering that
with a pre and a post show and all that
fun stuff but then on top of that we
also have all these wonderful guests
friends from around the internet are
gonna be joining us every weekday to do
some live streams and to donate some
money to Direct Relief to help frontline
workers battling Kovan which is very
exciting this would be a very good to
feel very good about that that's I'm
really glad we're doing that yeah you
don't you don't want to miss it
so yeah please be excited for that
stay tuned that should be great it kicks
off on Monday and yeah you come back
every day to GameSpot for something new
for like a month
oh no damn yet to you you will donate
money
that's not what I want to do Huijin
please nice nice nice
oh that's on me no okay good okay we got
final round you know something I really
like about first off the stage is great
like I'm appreciating all the stained
glass windows and stuff there I really
appreciate how MORTAL KOMBAT probably
more so than any other fighting game
franchise really really leans into like
the 90s arcade nostalgia yeah in a way
that I think is is really cool you got a
lot of cool stuff going on yeah I
appreciate it I don't remember wind
where does everyone is early it's a
different time it's early it's a
different time that we normally do it
which is a lot there's a lot going on
but we're happy you're here
amen thanks for hanging out
huijin's really I wish that I were
better with seemed to probably spend
more time playing anything school just
got he's a flippin ninja with wind power
and a gun let me switch back to scorpion
for a hot minute and just see if I can
like get my my sea legs go in here all -
what up anime girl
hell yeah you want I'll do it I don't
want to do it but I'll do it you don't
have to do it we're gonna want man yeah
I feel like you have to though he's he's
a fan favorite what room can join you
can definitely join we're on PC and the
room name is games yes but yeah again
it's is PC
ah so angry man you know we should do
next week we should we should do we
should do PS oh hell yeah yes I think we
got a foot we got to figure out what our
schedule is like how our community
Friday's is gonna work with play for all
happening every day but ideally I'd
still like to do community Fridays every
every Friday it would be kind of cool I
think we can we can make it work I'll
figure it out there might be some some
days where we can't if something else is
going on but we will we'll try our best
to still keep community Friday's going
poke every single one of these grabs
can't deal with it and wait in case
since 2006 missed this the new one is
really good what's up guys hope you're
doing well
dude same to you man we hope everyone
everyone's doing well dang
no I'll every time I used to know how to
like combo into stuff I've completely
forgotten everything about this game now
okay all right I'm here for real now I'm
doing it look I'm not here for real now
apparently
whoa ooh it's a referential boom oh yeah
uh uh uh I remembered it wow you
remembered it good job Chuck I am good
job you gotta make sure we get that look
back yeah that's nice
every time oh love it we love to see it
I'm sorry I hit rematch oh you're good
so I keep going going with all your
characters try to turn remember all cool
things you can do
do you know I didn't really vibe well
with the Terminator before but I'm won't
we give him another shot yeah yeah I
thank me let me try if I've been with a
scarlet here scroll it is really cool
do you take it to the bone temple the
shin ox bone temple to the bone temple
man right I was like oh man I know it's
over on the right side yeah you're right
on it Jango um-um-um - all right playing
PSO and doing a whole bunch of Mortal
Kombat stuff this week right I'm ready
for a weekend
oh and everything's happening next week
it's gonna be wild and crazy oh yeah and
I'm excited mm-hmm just watched your
video on all the friendship things put
together I think the Terminator and
Jacksons are my favorites yes I'm saying
the jacks one is absolutely fantastic
Johnny asks if you could choose your
dream Kombat pack who'd you put in it mm
and they've already put like so many
well if I guess I would say Brent then
let's break this up into two categories
so like more Mortal Kombat characters
you want back in versus like just yeah
we're gonna keep the guest characters in
the theme of what Mortal Kombat is or
just anyone uh I think I think they did
they would let's be somewhat realistic
like they could reasonably be in mortal
combat all right it's like here you
would probably not show up in Mortal
Kombat yeah I guess for me guess
character I think flippy and Jim Slayer
would be really good do you fire would
be fantastic that's a really good path
and if it weren't doom Slayer it'd be
ash Williams but I'm still very certain
that they're still adding him or um PGI
blaskowitz oh heck yeah I feel it all
all the good Bethesda boys in there you
could do some really fun stuff with with
him
I gotta get something important yeah
that's really good
get the over here oh dang oh my god Ben
Jesus oh I forgot about us is for the
terminate ability and I was just like oh
wait yeah you just walked forward and
you just do [ __ ]
that's good also I forgot that he has
that real easy to do air grab and just I
went for it
john-boy could be in there for sure it's
a good fit
yeah yeah he'd be a good one um who else
would I want cuz I mean if they've
already covered they've already covered
a lot of the ones like so for what I
really want this is like not mortal
combat related but sort of it's like
what I would really want is is I want in
other realms to just make like the
monster movie fighting game they've
basically made already yeah that they
basically if you were to take nine 10
and 11 s guest characters and put them
all into one game there you go you'd be
done you'd be like re you got spawned
Robocop Terminator and then you got like
alien predator you got you have Jason
you have Freddy like you just put all
those take all of that and then just put
that in one game and then like boom done
like that's what I would want I'm into
it
blade blade would be great blades a good
one didn't really what would fit in real
well yeah like I would I would just they
so clearly want to make it and I would
just I would love for that to happen
I think that'd be so cool if they just
made their own like monster movie
license game but I imagine on some level
it's probably easier to just put them
into something like Mortal Kombat than
to
that as its own game like like not not
that it wouldn't sell well but like a
license wise
I imagine that somewhat easier but I'd
like to see it happen yeah I run away
from that dynamite though the dynamite
was just chilling no no oh well just do
it or it this is a bad play cuz it's
probably not gonna get me the round boy
just want to see it biome no come on oh
are you bad man
thank you I love that that meter bird
version of the dynamite that I stood on
yeah
oh geez jump off the bail I guess I
wasn't ready for that
oh nice
just like just like playing smash yeah
you got a got to set that up good see c4
all over the place no no Judge Dredd
would be really good too we have a
mechanic for him switching like shots
and his gun and all that
no the huh
what kind of name is star this Crusader
clearly you're not a connoisseur of the
fine art that is anime you should
probably watch Jojo isn't ours from a
stream I don't remember any of his his
fatalities I used it's it's been a while
okay so Aaron black not my character
he's he's cool cowboy but I'm not we're
gonna play while I'm still in this
waiting room oh yeah we should do
totally forgot about other people I'm
caught up from playing the game each
apologies let's do it
look at that win-loss oh yeah
heck yeah man kick my ass let's do it
she's ready for it scorpion good son
rain or Omak I'd like I'd like to see
rain and our Mac back if for other
Mortal Kombat characters I like playing
or Mac more than I like playing rain
yeah that's true yeah it's terms of
actual playing definitely our Mac but
both of them make an appearance in the
the [ __ ] mode and then die horribly in
it no no all right they're gonna pick
scorpion they're definitely gonna kick
my ass okay if anything we'll get to see
some real cool scorpion combos we will
get to see some real cool scorpion
combos epic Johnny Cage Oh it says you
have a 64 percent chance to win that's
not right that's a lie I'm no math
magician
Oh smoke I love smoking in a in nine
hear that wacky hairdo yeah I also
really liked
cyrix yeah I know they they kind of put
all three of them in tribe org and you
know ten DLC but that's not the same
yeah I want I want Molina back just for
the people who want Molina like I could
take her or leave her but those people
are very passionate yeah after this if
they kick my ass
they're gonna kick your ass we'll watch
I don't know if you can watch though
unless you make like a lobby can you not
watch no I just have to sit outside wait
oh no
okay well I guess they'll kick my ass in
cyber Sub Zero was really cool too
Seibert subzero was cool fun little
guest character feel like he's kind of
think of this is like frost frost
assorted the replacement for that
yeah frost is cool but some about cyber
sub-zero that was like cooler again
really cool like swords and stuff yeah
the match should be an MK yeah Jon why
not
that'd actually be really fun that's
what you would put in that monster movie
game I'm talking about
he put the mask in there it's he doesn't
have any other lines of dialogue except
smoke in like the character I'm here to
get revenge for my family and then the
mass just walks up and says samokhin and
that's it that'd be pretty good damn
dude
that's guys good as expected James Bond
would be pretty good
what's next Bugs Bunny I mean I is a
Warner property isn't it the Looney
Tunes laughter did you get it in there
all under the Scorpion and Bugs Bunny
are your coworkers
there we go him here that fatality man
or that friendship or something
Oh Daffy Duck - iron man yeah you got me
with the friendship good I think you
could probably get like some like not
some front-running like Avengers type
superheroes but you'd get like Lobo and
they're just flip it yeah and justice
forgot about injustice Astro Snake
Plissken
oh yeah still remember let's do it back
let's get the run back oh you do have
another person in here by the way oh
okay I'll let him kick my ass one more
time we'll hop back in well I'll fight
that other person yeah what everyone
wanted shaggy in mortal combat is the
thing that I'm pretty sure was mostly
for the meme yeah that was definitely
just did weird mean thing I uh I thought
it was funny for a hot minute but I kind
of got off the plate real quick that's a
joke the seat from that movie though the
people complain was pretty good where he
beat up all the dudes in a bar
oh yeah damn dude
yo have it I'm PC nice get in here man
ah I'm something to get at least one
fatal blow if he perfect me on sometimes
sometimes you gotta you know honestly
they some kind of beautiful about that
so that guy go was nice chillin and
sharing yeah thanks for hanging out it
was good hanging out have a good rest
you you Jane your weekend I love that
we'd stream on Friday so I can tell
people that have a good weekend
alright scorpion boss I'm gonna go check
out this other person I'm gonna let them
kick my ass every turns
oh they left ah man
but we might have someone coming in soon
cuz cuz we got people in the chat but it
would be cool she's Deathstroke model
from injustice and just add a few jokes
yeah Deadpool would fit in really well
Deadpool will fit in well trying to
think of king of the hill yeah give him
good King and Hilda match uh how do we
do that can we can we get multiple
people on king of the hill yeah in
silicon twelve person that's a normal
low let's do that then actually like
here just hit this and invite both of
you guys scorpions in versus those
this is just with other random people
not our lobby does anyone in the lobby
you can start outside of this but I can
just invite people from the all these
people are in the lobby oh you did a
different thing I was inviting one here
you'd I think he had something else oh
oh I don't know yeah you you just went
off onto another thing I don't know how
that happened all right you and you
invite me again I'm back okay did that I
don't think I think I matchmake into
like a different lobby somehow there we
go open it up and I think people can
join onto that from here now you can
watch people play until then perfect
that's what we want to do the thing I'm
getting a full screen you like yeah I
can't I can't stream this game and not
play Johnny Cage at least once let me
try I'd like casting theory but I was
never good with her she's a really cool
character
I'm gonna try fujin again I still want
to try and figure him out
alright
take it to the club do you head yeah
y'all so a fight already exists with
Mugen yeah I mean I guess if you want
sheer volume of characters but I've
never been a fan of how moving plays but
I guess you could also have different
types of movements but it's it's an
interesting spectacle for sure just a
heads up Dragon Ball Z fan we're only
gonna be gone for about another 20
minutes pretty short stream today just
how busy it is so if it's gonna take too
long apologies about that but this will
be the last time you stream Mortal
Kombat definitely not I like it
your hold on don't do anything through
these fine I did a lot of damage it did
it was because it's a it's a one of
those x-ray brutal attacks also I just
realized this variant styles called
Airbender and that just straight up
looks like the the airbenders icon from
Avatar
I don't know very good I don't know if
that's intentional or not or if that's
deserted or Earth on some level that
like that icon is just sort of like a
from from something else like kind of
but look at Universal like a monk kind
of air air symbol no no aftermath we're
at the price we've seen a lot of people
online quite upset about it so yeah
basically I think it's worth the price
it's a it's actually a very good deal if
you've never played Mortal Kombat 11 or
don't own it because you get the base
game aftermath and that the combo pack
or the fighter pack for like 60 bucks
which is honestly a extremely good deal
that's a ton of content
yeah but aftermath by itself is 40s I
tell is 40 so people who have already
would bought the game at 60 when it
launched and bought the fighter pack
which was like what 40 or 50 bucks it's
yeah and then bought aftermath for 40
that's a lot of money so I understand
people on that front feeling like it's
too much I think that's a very very fair
fair feeling to have so yeah it's kind
of it's a weird one maybe used to want
to let me grab you at all no I don't
back here
whoa now oh oh I don't I don't know it
let's do it do an easy one I don't know
I don't know they needed stuff I like
they had it easy fatalities is like an
option but I don't like that you have to
basically pay for them yeah none of that
that's my [ __ ] I seems you could burn
like the hearts oh wow okay yeah I'll do
it
no I hit what why'd you hit I'd tried to
hit a score because you swear people
after you fight them and it took too
long anywhere else in here we go up we
do yes you got you got ya people and
hanging out perfect as always should
have been doing from the beginning all
right thanks guys got to go but enjoy
the restroom and stay safe stay safe -
you too Johnny
thank you for joining us we appreciate
it he's got that like Saints throw
purple colors going yeah yeah I do I'll
be the stage
it's a cross play between Xbox and ps4
from Mortal Kombat 11 if that's what you
were saying right then yeah I'm pretty
sure there is de patch it in a long time
ago but not not PC the Loom nope
since when are you in sub zero besties I
do love the part of Johnny Cage that is
just him thinking things are a movie
yep like it's really really good and
then his like fatalities eventually
showing that it is a movie sort of kind
of it is a movie but that guy's also
very much dead in the game soon good
good because we're we're we got like 15
minutes left
yeah before we can get in for at least a
game then we got to go back to work I've
got people already hitting me up on
slack and it's not even alert it's it's
uh it's wild
Oh
oh nice
got that brutality on me oh there he is
you did the reference - well done all
right Johnny Cage is so good though pay
my respects dude
10 out of 10 respect blammo
all right listen who's next
our two guest people here excellent now
we get to watch professionals let them
fight
that's weird I love it
it's a wallpaper you know everyone's
favorite Liu Kang hanging them no I was
actually referring to I don't fits on
your screen but on the loading screen
for me instead of showing the right like
combos it just said like to do this
combo do yeah like at down at one that's
like you got it the new tweet fight mode
where you have to actually fight people
by tweeting Oh like uh what remember
that game hash tag I dub by Darb start
yeah it holds up a premonition team in
it yeah uh that can be sports yeah I
like it its achievements also worth a
lot of points to do which is wild so
it's like if you score three baskets in
a row you get like a hundred fifty
gamerscore
and that's pretty he's got that fire god
Liu Kang with fire crowd Liu Kang not a
playable character in the original game
I don't think it's just the the build of
the skin yeah alright cuz there is a
skin for it you're right I wasn't sure
if he was like a different character but
no I think you're right I think it's
just the skin
this is a really cool stage to
have you did you beat the story mode for
aftermath oh yeah is it good so far yeah
it's apparently like three hours long
but that's pretty honestly so it's just
really good action movie fight scenes
and like kind of going over story but
redoing it interesting times that's a
good times yeah awesome
that's exciting I'm really blazblue
nonsense yeah I I enjoyed Mortal Kombat
11 story quite a bit so I definitely
want to check that out
sorry for terribly it's fine you still
understand you
yeah yeah we we were just talking about
that the fire-god Liu Kang I think I
think it was just the skin now that I
think about it I don't remember if when
you put him in the story mode if he
actually did different moves or not
whoo some arranging happening I do want
to watch that scorpion movie I haven't
found time to yet though I heard it's
pretty good it's pretty good too I've
heard the the the like animation and the
fighting is really really good I think I
know what the 1 this one is it's the
disconnect fatality boom my god my god
more combat that's horse man
like he wasn't even that high off the
ground and then getting like thrown down
on the ground so hard that that happens
right that's a lot that's a lot
all right uh I think it's gonna be you
right oh yeah I'm back in uh Who am I
gonna be what's it gonna do I do like a
ball of it he's a pretty cool guy yeah
let's go with him
the soul chamber yeah the disappointment
was enough like he had to wrap him up in
he blows up Oh so again
yeah a cabal fighter show time same well
I don't think there are a lot of people
who we've seen playas cabal at least
it's true which is funny because he was
pretty popular in nine yeah he was very
easy to play in nine to I think was the
the big thing him in smoke I remember
we're like like him smoking scorpion
were like the go-to you'd see the most
often from what I remember at least in
the early early stages when I when I
played online
I remember the the the combo buttons for
him we just keep running India it's the
best way to do it there this is the
autograph
hey Brendon howdy
happy Friday thanks for tuning in
sorry the stream started an hour early
otherwise I'm sure you would have been
here it's a real crazy day for us so we
we needed a start on the earlier side
unfortunately we're only gonna be going
for about an hour so we're gonna be
stopping actually pretty soon but we
appreciate you coming in at least for a
little bit to say what's up oh oh there
it is oh it's very nice of him
run it back what it literally run it
back oh so close that [ __ ] you've let me
have that run you let this go into a
third third fight and then God make it
fun it's true I like it
my eyes I see it it's smart I can't
blame me for it oh nice oh man that's
good who me I play games so much this
week is made me just be like I wish I
could like spend it back and do it again
no this is the worst everyone's joining
in right as the streams ending Borah
toast dad is here that's what didn't
expect the time shifts yeah very sorry
about that guys it was a very
last-minute thing this is my chance to
pitch it I guess the Reta the whole
reason we had to start early is because
we're really busy today because we are
prepping for play for all which is our
month long
III style charity event we're doing it
starts on Monday June 1st and basically
the whole idea is that we're gonna be
you know doing interviews with devs and
putting out videos every day we're gonna
be covering live streams with pre and
post shows as usual like we would for e3
so if you remember oh I'm playing I
should probably pick somebody if you
remember the PlayStation has their event
on Thursday so you can expect us to be
covering that in addition to that we're
gonna be doing daily charity livestreams
every day at 12 p.m. to 2 p.m. Pacific
time we're gonna be having a bunch of
guests on from all over the place on the
internet a lot of cool people thinking
like Greg Miller is gonna be here giant
bomb guys we got Troy Baker a lot of
cool cool guests and we're gonna be
donating money to Direct Relief which is
a charity that sends supplies to the
frontline workers who are battling Co
vid 19 and I feel really really good
about that I'm really glad we're doing
that so big thing be excited for that
come back on Monday because every day
for like the next month I guess about
we're gonna be having just new [ __ ]
going on which is gonna be great don't
miss it
it'll be a good time for everyone still
think the stage is maybe the prettiest
yeah I'm I'm a big fan of it let's love
although like the leaves animated moving
with the breeze it's just so nice
sure Johnny Cage guests in other
fighting games yeah but Johnny Cajon in
I don't know Soul Calibur put put John
Cage in back in actually think - like
the the super violence he'd actually fit
really well in there yeah you just don't
have to make him violent for that one
yeah I think it would actually fit
really well home tekken we're seniors
thinking about I'm like yeah yeah I
could I can't get behind that it's one
of those things that would never happen
just because of a how both what I just
think so Mortal Kombat vs Street Fighter
right it's the thing we all want yeah
I've always thought about like how would
you make that work because there's one
there's like the weird licensing thing
of like I just don't know if that ever
happened like an American fighting
studio teaming up with Capcom I don't
know if that would ever ever even happen
but on top of that the games play so
fundamentally differently I don't know
how you would uh how you'd make that
work I'm sure they'd fun people are
resourceful especially getting actual
but the GS crew is while I always turn
in well don't worry in addition to
special guest we will also have members
of the GameSpot staff on those journeys
dreams as well so before that that's
really cool sorry been interrupted you I
died to get the plug-in like your plug
is more important than whatever I was
gonna say I was gonna say something else
about what you're saying on top yeah rip
Tekken X Street Fighter yeah man they've
never officially cancelled they it's
someone somewhere has like a playable
build of that and it's just sitting or
or like a design doc or something
it's just sitting there like they had
gameplay of it at one point oh they did
oh wow okay slay they had a playable
something somewhere dang dang alright
man we got a couple more people in here
but unfortunately we're about to end it
oh I like combo breaker but in the
banners say no no ghosts that's good
actually I just said you'd never see
collector either no you also don't looks
like they're I haven't seen a lot of
collector so this is kind of nice thank
you GameSpot thank you thank you for
tuning in thank you for supporting us in
in any way you can just by by being here
you know it means a lot then to make
sure that you don't miss any of this
stuff definitely subscribe to the
channel so you get notified whenever any
of it goes live yeah it's the best way
to keep up to date on it all man I
really wish that a YouTube had like a
more you could like really customize
your notification like yeah like I wish
there was a way you could just say hey
just notify me one gamespot streaming or
just notify me when you could like even
do like like playlists so like I care
about the podcast right I care about
GameSpot after dark notify me when a new
after dark comes out right Mike come on
YouTube the campaign like that has to be
a highly requested feature like I'm sure
a lot of people would love that both
both creators and and audience members
right
dang that was awesome good collector
gameplay Oh No walk away a whole Johnny
Cage is back crack damn need to see it
uh okay so we should probably call here
unfortunately right cuz cuz it's 11:00
you got a lot going on Ben I got a lot
going on all right we got it we got we
got things we got to do preparations to
make for next week thank you everybody
who has joined us everyone right here
who is in this lobby plane with us
apologies to anyone who joined in late
and jointly on the stream running late
trying to play with us it's been a
shorter one today because like we said
it's really busy but we're doing get a
middle finger Wow peace out okay you're
cool you're not cool yeah it's fine I
know you're joking but yeah thank you
everyone for joining like I said we are
crazy busy with play for all we're gonna
be doing lots of stuff around that so
please please come back on Monday at
GameSpot because we're gonna be doing
that stuff all month long it should be a
great time and yeah I mean me and Ben
will still be around we're gonna still
keep trying to do community Fridays when
we can I think we're gonna try and hit
up Phantasy Star Online 2 because that
game is is out now anything else you
want to say about some technical issues
but hopefully they get sorted out but
I'll just come here come out come back
next week and that's really I could say
if you didn't get a chance to play
Mortal Kombat don't worry I'm sure we'll
play it again because they're more
character just coming out for it
I'm sure yeah absolutely alright guys
well thank you so much for joining us
and we'll see you next time see ya
that's good good one gray fox you got it
you